Hey Team it’s Charlie and this week’s
episode of Doctor Who did an amazing job of
tying back into the idea of changing mistakes
of the past.
Peter Capaldi himself described it as a combination
of Ocean’s Eleven and 2001 Space Odyssey.
I would also add the Wizard of OZ to that.
So let’s do top 5 moments, easter eggs and
then the review.
And quick reminder, the weekly giveaway is
open again.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment.
Careful for spoilers from the episode.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay.
Here are my top 5 moments.
Number 5 - The Bank of Karabraxos
If this was supposed to be a little bit Ocean’s
Eleven, I’m guessing Karabraxos is the Bellagio
Hotel.
This was probably one of the most well developed
new locations in series 8.
Because of the macguffin of the Heist they
were able to describe every detail of the
planet and the bank down to the last spec
of dust.
I wish we could get a big episode like that
inside the TARDIS.
Even Journey to the Center of The TARDIS in
series 7 didn’t explain the interior workings
of the TARDIS as well as Time Heist explained
the Bank of Karabraxos.
The culture of the bank was just as interesting.
Did you catch when they killed the Red Shirt
at the beginning?
Miss Delphox said they were going to terminate
his account, meaning the bank would seize
his assets and they’d throw his family in
jail.
That seems a bit harsh.
Maybe Moffat hates white collar criminals.
It also explains how Miss Karabraxos could
become the wealthiest person in the Universe.
If she just kept terminating accounts and
taking people’s fortunes.
I liked the idea of the architect even though
the reveal was kind of obvious.
The other direction I thought they could have
gone would have been for the Doctor himself
to be the architect.
And had his mind wiped.
That would have messed the whole plot up.
And they already did the multiple mind wipes
joke with Strax during the 2012 Christmas
Special.
The solar storm that destroyed the planet
was the same type of storm that destroyed
all the gangers during Rebel Flesh and Almost
People.
Not the same storm, but the same type of storm.
Number 4 - The New Monster The Teller
Technically not a monster as we learned.
But as far as the episode explained it’s
psychic and prevents people for stealing or
cheating the bank.
I lot of you told me on twitter it reminded
you of the Minotaur from God Complex.
In both cases the story was about turning
your own thoughts against you.
There was a nice moment when it was scanning
the Doctor’s Brain that I wondered if we’d
get some big clue about Missy.
I just ended up being the Madam Karabraxos
reveal but it did make us think about the
TARDIS phone again.
I’ll talk more about the phone during my
review.
Because the Doctor did way to many mimed phone
calls at people for it to be a throwaway joke.
I would have liked to learn a little more
about the Teller creatures but now that they’re
canon, they can always come back.
I feel like Moffat wouldn’t create something
with those kind of powers if he didn’t intend
for the Doctor to ask a favor of them in exchange
for saving their lives.
Back in Deep Breath he said he remembered
his face but he didn’t remember why he picked
it.
It’s possible the teller’s could deep
scan his brain to find out or give him a clue.
Number 3 - The Doctor’s Toys offer some
clues about Missy
I don’t know if the Dimensional Shift Bomb
was timelord technology but he had it on him
and I don’t think anyone else gave it to
him.
And then there was the quick return buttons
he handed out.
As for the Bomb, He said instead of exploding
it sends particles to another plane of existence.
He didn’t say which plane or if it was like
E-Space or a pocket universe.
The quick return capsules were tied to the
TARDIS, so I’m guessing those were timelord
technology.
If Missy had her own TARDIS, that could be
how she’s snagging people.
It’s still a little soon to tell.
I always love new gadgets.
Like David Tennant’s machine that goes Ding
in the 50th.
It makes it feel like the Doctor’s suits
also operate like the TARDIS and are bigger
on the inside.
Like they have infinite storage space in their
pockets.
Number 2 - The Private Vault
I’m going to have to re-watch this a couple
more times to see but I feel like there are
a lot of visual easter eggs for other bits
of Doctor Who history.
The egyptian symbols made me think of Pyramids
of Mars and the upcoming Mummy on the Orient
Express episode.
A lot of times set designers will insert their
own easter eggs when putting props in the
backgrounds of shots.
Things that aren’t really in camera focus,
but if you were on the set you’d be able
to see really clearly.
Doctor Who recycles a lot of their props too,
so sometimes when you see familiar things
it’s both them just being practical and
saving money and the set designer picking
things because they have some special significance.
Mark Gatiss explained that sometimes it just
ends up being a coincidence.
He was talking about his own writing, but
I like to think that people who are not Moffat
on the crew try to work in things they think
the fandom will pick up on.
So let me know if you saw anything in the
vault at the end that reminded you of stuff
from previous episodes.
and my Number 1 thing - Keeley Hawes new Villain
Madam Karabraxos and Miss Delphox
She is now the second biggest person this
season to play multiple roles in the same
episode.
Clara is the impossible girl, but I’m not
counting her.
Samuel Anderson played two different versions
of his character and now Keeley Hawes.
I wonder if the trend will continue.
I loved her character but I feel like she
got short changed a little.
Both versions of her character, Miss Karabraxos
and the clone Miss Delphox were really interesting.
And you could tell the clone had a life of
her own.
She was kind of like one of the gangers.
Add to that she was going to be thrown in
the incinerator just like the gangers getting
dumped in acid.
It’s important to remember that Madame Karabraxos
didn’t die at the end.
She’s still out there somewhere so Keeley
Hawes could always come back to reprise the
character.
I think one of my favorite things about the
big reveal was the way her story mirrored
the doctor’s.
And with her hating herself, all the deep
regrets about changing the past.
It’s what’s happening with The Doctor
right now.
It was a great way to tie the plot of the
episode to one of the big themes of series
8.
So my big questions for you guys is, what
was your favorite moment and do you think
we’ll see the Teller creatures or Keeley
Hawes again?
I already mentioned a lot of the references
I spotted like the gangers, the vault and
the tardis phone.
But here are all the criminals that popped
up on the screen.
There was the Terileptil, which was mentioned
during the Christmas Special.
The Slitheen also mentioned in the christmas
special.
A Sensorite from the Sensorites.
That was the seventh story from doctor who
season 1.
Absalom Daak from the comics.
Then there were a couple from the sarah jane
adventures including Androvax, The Trickster
and Captain John Hart from Torchwood
I feel like they were the biggest reference,
but if you saw any other big ones in the episode
just write them in the comments.
Overall I gave this episode a B, it was a
lot of fun but I felt like the plot dissolved
after they rescued the doctor and went down
to the vault.
Keeley Hawes was very interesting, she’s
a great actress.
But I feel like she didn’t get enough time
to develop her characters.
This whole thing with one actor playing multiple
versions of themselves seems very suspicious.
The supporting guest cast were a lot of fun.
I always wonder what and who Moffat plans
on bringing back at the end of each series.
Psi’s moment with Clara where he explains
deleting his family from his brain felt like
setup for Clara in a later episode.
I feel like the only problem I had with the
story was that the explanation was a little
too simple in the end.
There was all this build up for the first
half of the episode and wizard of oz style,
the curtain is thrown back and it’s a frail
dying person behind it all.
I think we can blame that on the episode this
year being less serialized.
As a result they have to completely set everything
up and resolve it in 50 minutes, so if it
feels like it was too easy for them to rob
the bank.
That’s why, they had to do Ocean’s Eleven,
a two plus hour movie, in under 50 minutes.
Actually they did the Ocean’s Eleven part
in under 40 minutes or so, the last ten was
wizard of oz.
It was still a lot of fun but I really do
like serialized stories more.
It just allows them to make more complex storylines.
I understand why they’re not doing that.
They just want to make it easier for new viewers
to follow.
Next week looks like a lot fun.
The Doctor will be play acting headmaster
at Coal Hill.
My next video is going to be my bonus story
for the christmas special this year.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
They just announced a bunch of guest actors.
so I’ll try to post that in 5 or 6 hours.
Don’t forget about the giveaway, I’ll
announce the winner in my Q&A on Sunday
Right now click here for the bonus video.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it.
and click here for the Q&A.
Thanks for watching, everybody high five and
we’ll meet up again in a couple hours to
talk about the christmas special!